[Music]
what's up reject nation it's your boy
John coming at you with another music
video reaction in fact I'm coming at you
with a pair of them because Janelle
Monae has dropped two new song with two
new music videos we are getting spoiled
today now I fully admit I don't know a
heap ton of Janelle monáe's music this
will be a journey for me and I'm excited
man I've heard some great things about
these songs I've heard some great things
about just her body of work in general
I've liked her in the movies I've seen
her in and as usual cannot show the
whole uncut music video here on YouTube
as it will get blocked so if you want to
see the full thing come on over and
check out our patreon we got a ton of
great exclusive content over there our
full music video reactions TV show
reactions behind the scenes stuff have
got a great community over there a lot
of good people come check us out if you
are so inclined yeah I'm excited to
check this out let's go this is the
first track is called make me feel let's
do it
[Music]
yeah Tessa Thompson
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's just the way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oday latex not bad alright alright as
I'm impressed me that's my first
go-around at least my first like focal
go around with a and boy that is a punch
coming out with new music that is a way
to say I am back and holy [ __ ] man that
was a groovy song I loved the build of
that song I love that it starts out with
a very gripping but very simple
structure you know you've just got this
electronic bass line and these you know
guitar twinkles and stuff these like
funky guitar twinkles and then as the
song goes you know you get these little
since stabs as it heats up and the
chorus comes in it just explodes and you
have some of those later moments where
it's like a literal onslaught of sounds
you know going from such a simple Tambor
to start with from something that builds
and builds and then really explodes it's
perfect to for the kind of song this is
I mean this is a very sexy song it's got
a lot of soul it's got a lot of rhythm I
love the imagery of this this is a
pretty straightforward video I mean
they're just going out to this
interesting looking Club with a lot of
dancing a lot of different scenes and
stuff I love the costume designs in this
I love the sets that they chose for this
guy's I love the colors I love the
designs and especially right now because
like there's so much eighties retro
stuff going on you know I see that in
this for sure but in a way that feels at
least to me kind of fresh kind of like
it's adapting those things for now like
for some reason this came together for
me as a complete whole in terms of the
song and the video I wasn't sitting
there going ah ha ha that the 1980s yes
it all kind of blended for me in the
perfect way it borrows from the 80s but
it's also very modern and it seems to be
what a lot of people are trying to do
right now or at least it seems that way
from the artists I've heard speak about
you know the new music that's been
coming out as a lot of people are trying
to do futuristic sounds but bring in you
know retro elements and I thought this
one really utilized both the funk
revival that's going on right now and
some of the soul revival that's going on
right now but it's also just by the end
of it this is a banger I really enjoyed
this song I love this I you know and I
like I'm gonna add
to a playlist or something you know ASAP
because I would definitely return to
this and listen to this I'm really
impressed by this so far I mean the the
singing is great the vocal performance I
mean it's a pretty straightforward song
generally but I like the writing here I
like the structure so yeah let's get in
the second track first and let's get
into the second of two this is called
Django Jane here we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
baby coaching
Ozzy
[Music]
[Music]
damn not bad at all this girl has a
one-two punch right there I mean to drop
these two togethers I think a really
good idea I love the contrast between
these two I mean especially in leading
up to a new album you know showcasing
two different sides of the sound I think
is a great idea and you know you start
with make me feel which is so fun and
sexy and funky you know you've got this
throbbing bass line these mouth clicks
and snaps and stuff these synths tabs
that come in that funk guitar and then
you move into Django Jane which has a
more restrained a little bit more of an
elegant environment with these strings
and these back mass pianos and stuff and
also just the switch between the singing
on the first track versus rapping you
know Django Jane she's rapping a lot in
this song and her bars are terrific I
think I mean this is a really gripping
song I feel like make me feel swept me
up and kind of got me loose and having
fun and then this song really demanded
my attention I think her confidence her
swagger who's on point in this even down
to the imagery you know she's in these
nice suits now make me feels very bubbly
very colorful and and Django Jane is too
but you know everyone's in suits she's
flanked by her squad it's very feminine
but in a very confident kind of way and
I really appreciate that about this
music video as well both of these videos
really kind of seem to support the tone
the themes of their songs really well
and I love what she's talking about here
I mean she discusses both her life
growing up her family as well as just
her hustle her music her place among all
this and just the state of things in
general I mean I think this is an
empowering a very confident song just in
terms of where we are in society it
seems like this is a moment where you
know she as a woman as a black woman is
taking the mic and I think this is a
really good statement of that kind of
thing it's your time this is your time
to have the mic I mean she really does
come off like a boss powerful you know
in this song like a like a queen like
the head of some sort of syndicate here
this seal almost seems like her lair of
some kind that we're watching this video
and it's very simple it's very contained
it's very much in this one set here it
seems like are these you know couple
sets but I think the way they shot it
you know the the simplicity
of it is kind of complimentary it's
restrained more than the first song but
it still backs up and fully molds around
the music I think just as well as the
first song does with two again very
different palates both of these songs
again just really swept me up with two
different flavors two different sides of
genell's art you know coming out of this
new album here and I really really
enjoyed both of these like I said before
this is sort of an early introduction
for me into genell's music but these two
songs if there are any indication I mean
I definitely am excited to hear more I
think there's a lot of great stuff going
on here really compelling really fun
catchy quotable all that stuff and there
are some great shots in these videos too
I think these are really well assembled
and again as just the one-two punch is
the thesis for an album I think this is
super successful and I am excited to
hear more so yeah awesome what you guys
think hit us up in the comments let us
know your thoughts as always I'm sorry
we have to cut these up for YouTube
otherwise they get blocked so if you
want to see the complete uncut
unadulterated reaction come check us out
over on patreon that'll be over there
and yeah that's it for now
thanks for joining me and as always you
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell to get notified
every time a review or a video is out
we're on the start as tab come check us
out over there download and follow us
first helps us out also check out viewer
reviews.com great new company we're
working with colleague your own personal
Rotten Tomatoes tailored to your taste
so yeah that's what we're ups you right
now and until next time guys Cheers
you